why are you so hell-bent on destroying
our lives I am doing what I have to do
for my husband was his west-allen
question is what are you looking to do
feels there's something you need to know
that will alter the outcome of this case
no idea what you think you're doing what
my husband won't name is a man I'm being
framed for something that I didn't do
he stood among us a wolf in sheep's
clothing you're gonna have evidence it's
the right thing to do Ralph just open
the door I'll do the rest if I testify I
have to lie I commit perjury I've become
exactly who they think I am then don't
lie tell everyone you're the flash
criminals knew my name they'd know my
weakness everyone that has stood by us
the last four years we have a target on
their back I was curious to imagine what
he does with his time it's almost like
he has this secret life is exactly what
DeVoe wanted a larger plan the flash
returns with an all-new episode this
Tuesday at 8/7 central
hey buddy surprise new flash trailer
with a whole bunch of new footage in it
we actually see some killer frost we see
the thinker examining what looks like a
giant scan of his body so let's break it
down there's a new round of that blast
ring giveaway - all you have to do to
enter that it'd just be a subscriber
leave about Flash related comments on
the video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this - it's kind of like new
footage day like we got all that venom
stuff but what they're teasing here is
that iris sounds like she's going to out
the flash in court like she says I have
something that will alter the outcome of
this trial I don't think that's what's
going on like they want you to think
that Barry is going to be forced to out
himself but the Flash's secret identity
is still relatively a big deal in the
comics like it seems like everybody's
learning everyone's secret identities on
all the TV shows but for the most part
the public is still in the dark
superhero secret identities are still
relatively important so you can see the
way they're trying to mess with your
mind
think like Barry's either gonna have to
out his identity lie in front of
everyone or Joe and the elongated me and
are gonna have to fight fire with fire
and plant evidence on the thinker so
that they can get him in trouble - but
if you've been reading comics for a long
time it's pretty easy to brush that
aside because one the flash is a good
person he doesn't murder people in cold
blood so that's why he didn't take the
thinker down in episode
9 I still get a lot of questions about
that how come he didn't kill the thinker
the flash does not kill people if he
doesn't have to that's why he didn't
kill the reverse-flash they had that big
line in the crossover episode that's
right Barry Allen does not kill people
he's probably not gonna perjure himself
and he's probably not going to give up
his secret identity if that was gonna
happen it would be like some big twist
in a later season like arrow isn't its
sixth season right now and they've done
that story so many times that is just
old news so whatever happens with the
trial in this next episode episode 11
he's still in trouble I think my episode
12 they'll start to wrap it up a little
bit even though the overarching conflict
with a thinker will still be going on
the trial stuff will largely have been
put past them but he'll still be under
this cloud of suspicion so they'll have
to be some sort of solution that allows
Barry to continue working at the police
station captain Singh is standing in
front of all these people too so I have
a feeling that even though he has his
doubts like they cut the trailer in a
really misleading way he'll probably
stick up for Barry too because the whole
thing about these next two episodes is
that the thinker is trying to drag his
name through the mud
to force him into a scenario whereby he
gives up his secret identity it keeps
him busy while the thinker in acts his
plan so really he's just trying to
distract Barry but I'm not expecting
that to reveal all that in episode 10
they actually were saying the actors
that the thinker's wife has some really
important scenes like they say that she
has one of the best performances of the
episode but I think they're mostly
talking about her acting during the
trial like she has to pretend that her
husband was murdered by Barry oh my god
I can't believe that he did this to my
family so that doesn't answer any
questions about what's going on with
these people passed out in the street
but it sounds like there's some sort of
villain of the week situation that Barry
is forced to help out in but because
he's in jail because of all this trial
stuff it sounds like the thinker is
trying to just throw everything he has
at them so that Barry gets caught and
everybody finds out that he's the flash
elongated man and Joe have this Jessica
Jones thing going on where they're
catching the thinker's wife boning with
the new version of the thinker who you
know - everyone else in the world would
seem like a totally different person but
they're sort of playing dirty pool fight
fire with fire so it'll be interesting
to see how dirty team flash is willing
to get before they find some sort of
solution
that doesn't completely demonize them
for the rest of the season like you want
to believe that these characters are
good so whatever their actual solution
is it will be something that doesn't
require them to be absolutely terrible
people but just remember that there's
still a lot of berry gibberish from that
first episode when he came out of the
speedforce with all those mystery
drawings that look like the drawings
that the thinker was making on his
blackboard in those flashbacks your
honor the city would say that there was
no residual danger but that's not true
they've kind of turned this house as
bitching into a joke just a bunch of
characters in different episodes all say
it just offhandedly so I'm interested to
see how many times in the back half of
the season people say it but I have a
feeling just beyond them trying to be
funny about it they're also just trying
to remind you about the gibberish
because they don't go back to it every
single episode like we haven't seen
Cisco actually try to decode anything so
eventually I think someone just gonna
keep saying this house is bitching in
Caitlin or Cisco will be like wait a
minute we should go back and try to
decode more of this because it sounds
like Barry got a vision of the future
when he was in the Speed Force because
of the way the time moves while he's in
there like he experiences past present
and future almost simultaneously like
time has no meaning inside the Speed
Force so he was spitting out dialogue
that will probably be paid off in the
finale some of them were a little more
gibberish than others like we're gonna
need more diapers definitely implies
that iris might get pregnant at the end
of the season or realize that she's
pregnant the other stuff like the stars
are raining that sounds like it's gonna
have something to do with the big final
battle with the thinker but just as a
rule of thumb if you want to catch up go
back and watch that first episode again
and just listen to the jibberish
dialogue before you watch episode 10
just to refresh your memory because it
has been a while in really big news this
weekend if you didn't hear they're doing
a bunch of special DC TV panels geoff
johns is gonna be there they'll be
talking about the flash there'll be a
bunch of people from all the different
shows so that's not happening till
Saturday morning but whatever it is that
they do I'll do a video for it so just
look out for special Comic Cons
over the weekend but in related news
there was so much comic-book stuff that
dropped today so what happened is is
they push the New Mutants movie that
Fox's making til almost next year it's a
February movie next year now but
Deadpool 2 is coming to theaters two
weeks sooner in May right around Han
Solo in right after infinity war so it
is gonna be crazy there's probably gonna
be a whole bunch of Super Bowl trailers
we'll find out about that in the next
week or two usually Studios wait till
the last minute to confirm plans like
that just because it costs millions and
millions of dollars for those really
short TV spots like I said there's a new
flash ring giveaway in this video
announce the winner when I post new DC
but congratulations to the winner from
my last video Jack please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details click
here to rewatch that venom teaser again
and click here to learn about the brand
new dark flash bonus story that they're
doing during season 4 thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight